- [Instructor] In this
video, we're gonna discuss
different types of forces,
but we're gonna do it in the context
of free body diagrams.
So let's say I have a table here,
and I have a block that is
sitting stationary on that table.
What are all of the forces
that are going to act on this blocK?
Well, to do that, to think about that,
I can draw a free body diagram
where I am only going to draw the block.
Remember, in free body diagrams,
you only care about the
forces acting on one
of the the objects in your system.
So, if we're looking at only the block,
what's going on?
We're going to assume that
the block is on earth,
we're assuming that it's stationary.
Well, if it's on earth,
the block has some weight.
You have the force of
gravity acting on the block.
And so let me draw that
in my free body diagram.
So you're gonna have a downward force,
and it's magnitude is gonna be F sub g.
We could also call that or w.
And even though this block
had contact with a table
which maybe has contact with the earth,
weight, or the force of
gravity is a long-range force.
Even if this block was in orbit,
even if it wasn't in
orbit, it would still have
gravitational interactions with the earth.
The earth would still be pulling on it.
But going back to this free body diagram,
if this was the only
force acting on the block,
the block would accelerate downwards.
But we're assuming that it's stationary.
So there must be another
force that is netting out
against the force of gravity.
Now, what would that be?
Well, that would be the force
of the table pushing on the block.
And this force of pushing in a direction
that is perpendicular to
the surface of an object,
that's known as normal force.
And its magnitude you could
denote as capital F sub N.
Let's do another example, but this time,
instead of having the block on a table,
let's say it is hanging from a string
which is attached to the ceiling.
But once again, everything is stationary.
Draw a free body diagram for that.
Well, once again, I am only
concerned with the block.
It's still on earth, we're assuming.
So you're going to have
the force of gravity
acting downwards on the block.
But what's keeping it from
accelerating downwards?
Well, you might say,
well, you got the string
that's holding it up,
that is pulling on it.
And that pulling force
is known as tension.
So what you would have
here is an upward force
that nets out against
the force of gravity.
And sometimes its magnitude
is denoted by capital T
or it might be a F sub T.
Now, let's make things a
little bit interesting.
Let's try to kind of combine these things,
and we'll actually introduce a new force.
So let's say that we, this is
the ground right over here.
I have a block on the ground.
And I have a situation where I am pulling
on this block using a rope
with a force of magnitude,
let's just call this
the force of tension.
I am pulling on that block.
But the block is not moving.
What would be the free body
diagram for this block?
Well, I'll do the same thing again.
I will draw the block.
Now, in the vertical direction,
you have the same thing that
you saw in that first scenario.
You're going to have the force of gravity
or the weight of the block
pulling downward on the block.
And that's going to be
counteracted by the normal force
of the ground on the block.
The ground is holding up the block
is one way to think about it,
keeping it from accelerating downwards.
So the normal force is acting upwards.
But what about the horizontal direction?
I already said that I'm
pulling to the right
with a force of magnitude F sub T.
So let me do that on my free body diagram.
So this would be F sub T.
But I said it's stationary.
So there must be something
that is counteracting that,
that is netting against that,
going in that direction.
What force would that be?
Well, that would be the force of friction.
We've all experienced
trying to pull on something,
trying to drag something across the ground
and it doesn't move, and
that's because there's friction
between the object and the ground.
And friction, fundamentally, it could be
because the surfaces of
the two objects are rough
and you kind of have to
grind them pass each other.
Or sometimes it can even be
due to molecular interactions
where they're kind of sticky,
where the objects are
attracted to each other
and you gotta pull passed that.
And so in this situation, you
have the force of friction
counteracting this pulling
force, the force of tension,
the force of friction.
And the force of friction
is really interesting,
because it always goes against
the direction of sliding,
it always goes against motion.
Now, with all of these
examples out of the way,
let's try to do a more complex scenario.
Let's say that I have a shelf,
and it has a weight of
10 newtons.
Sitting on that shelf I have an object
that has a weight of five newtons.
And let's say I have two wires
and everything is symmetric,
but this weight is right on the middle,
and these wires are at both
of the ends of the shelf,
and this is wire one and this is wire two
and they are attached to the ceiling.
And for the sake of simplicity,
we're gonna assume that
the wires have no weight.
In actuality they would,
but for the sake of this argument,
let's assume that they are weightless.
What would be a free body diagram
for this five newton block
that sits on the shelf?
Well, that one is actually
pretty straightforward,
and it's analogous to this
first scenario that we saw.
You have your block, you
have the force of gravity
pulling down with a force
of magnitude, five newtons,
and that's gonna be
counteracted by a normal force
of the same magnitude but going upwards.
So make sure I have enough space.
So that's gonna be counteracted
with the normal force
which is going to be equal
to five newtons upwards.
And to be clear, this five newtons,
this is equal to the weight, the magnitude
of the weight of the object.
So that was pretty straightforward,
the free body diagram for just the block.
And it's really important to see that,
because notice, in the free body diagram,
all you see is the block.
But now let's draw the free
body diagram for the shelf.
So if I have a shelf right over here.
Pause this video and try to do that.
Well, we know its weight, it's 10 newtons.
So we can do that first.
So,
it has a weight of 10 newtons,
so the force, the magnitude of the force
of gravity downwards is 10 newtons.
Is that the only downward force?
Well no, you have this
object that's sitting on it,
and gravity is pulling down on that object
with a force of five newtons,
and that causes that object
to push on our shelf.
So that pushing force is
actually a normal force.
It's due to the gravity on
that five newton object,
but the end result of
the five newton object
is pushing down on our shelf.
So what you have is another
force that is pushing down.
And it is going to be a five newton force.
And really, we should view
that as a normal force.
It's a contact force, it's a pushing force
of the five newton object
on the 10 newton shelf.
So this is going to have a
magnitude of five newtons.
Assuming that it's completely stationary,
there must be some
counteracting forces here.
Where is that gonna come from?
Well, that's gonna come
from the pulling forces of these wires.
So you're going to have
the tension from rope one,
we could call that T sub one,
and you're gonna have the tension
from wire or rope two, T sub two.
And because this thing is stationary,
T sub one plus T sub two should be equal
to 10 newtons plus five newtons.
So I'll leave you there.
We've done a nice survey of various forces
you might see in a first
year physics class.
And we've been able to think about them
in the context of free body diagrams.